有绿色的
那这是尾盘的状况
有的尾盘第一笔
像这个是第五笔
通常那个连次量都爆得很大的话
它就会反转
那连次量我稍微解释一下
有的人刚第一次来
我不知道它的意思
它每五秒钟会计算一次
每五秒钟计算一次
然后计算外盘的成交量
还是内盘成交量哪个大
那假如外盘成交量大了
它就变成红色一次
然后记外盘的量
那只要到了十次之后呢
连续十次都是外盘获胜
这时候呢
我们的那个我们的手机啊
就会有语音出来
举来讲
他可能讲连帽
买盘爆量
那这时候我们就准备来抓捷径了
所以我
一直以来我抓捷径的方法
都是运用手机的连次量来告诉我
连次量呢
你就可以把它想象成
那个红色代表多军获胜
那绿色代表空军获胜
那连续十次多军获胜
那后面就会来到了利捷
利期就是买盘就会比较
后面会比较美丽
叫买盘的捷径
那卖盘呢也会有
连续的绿色呢会有卖盘的捷径
所以盘中呢我们是用这个呢
来抓捷径点
这个是来抓捷径点
但是呢
你要抓红黑K
红黑K呢
就必须要有
这个平常我们的教学
我们在某种状况下
就会告诉你说
在今天这种状况下
它就容易红K
红黑K呢
要从这边来看
像我在礼拜天
我就跟学生讲
全新今天容易黑K啊
全新今天容易黑黑
所以我们就有很多学员
今天都有做到全新的黑黑
那全新黑黑怎么做呢
其实很简单
就是你先建立空单
也就是卖单
那做当中呢
就有分先卖再买先买再买而已
那这个我们待会再跟各位讲
讲清楚一点
我今天光当中赚了400万
我赚了整团的团费了
跟我出国呢
我们的学员他只要怎么样小秘书当然是我要攻攻击飞机机票住宿的钱我全部都报了我们的其他团员们
我们就是鸡家酒治理
然后我们的食食
吃东西都不用
我们这边都会处理
吃的我们都会处理
像今天赚的
整团的机票加住宿
家吃的全部都赚得到
这笔金的都够
都够付了
那这个所以呢
你可以从当冲
当冲有个好处
就是你可以来回一直做
那你假如是
现股当冲的话
你只要准备
准备怎么样
准备你有可能会输的钱
或者是有可能不小心得交割的钱
准备这些
你假如说
你完全不能准备要交割的钱
那我还是建议你不要当冲好了
那你的压力会特别大
很多人都说
那我没钱要不要学当中
我真的强烈建议你
没钱好好赚钱
没钱不要来学当中
因为没钱你做当中
你压力会非常非常大
最好是有点钱来做当中
心里会比较踏实一点
那各位先加一下这个讨论群
先加一下
那遇到任何问题呢
可以打在聊天室上
小哥都会看到
那提问呢
请理性不要洗瓶
不然小编会封手
那今天虽然是免费课程
我们今天
哇在刚刚回来的时候
路边很多夹娃鸡店
我们都不能去
为什么要回来直播
不然我是很想去的
所以今天虽然是免费课程
但内容绝对是付费的等级
一定是的
我们教的东西都很有料
为什么
因为我们长期都是靠我们教的东西来做交易
所以各位可以找个安静的地方来听完这堂课
你会收获满满的离开
好 交易经济
特长上提到标记
其中教学研究
物质投资参考
投资交友赚有赚
风险大家多加小心
那大部分看到
大部分散户看到当中会有两种反应
第一个觉得它很危险
所以完全不敢碰
我跟各位讲当中真的很危险
你假如不会控制部位的话
它真的很危险
第二个呢觉得它很刺激很爱当冲但教育绩效很差大部分都这样大部分人做当冲很多人都凭感觉凭感觉建议你不要冲
凭感觉建议你不要冲
你一定要怎么样
你一定不能凭感觉
你要凭的是数据
所以像真正懂当冲的人
我跟各位讲
我真正懂当冲
我连今天要做全新
我都可以在两天前
这个跟学员讲
我们两天前很多人在台北厂都有听到
我今天要做全新的
我两天前都可以知道
那这些是因为我们有很多统计数据
可以支撑我今天可以做的全新
那所以呢
这个做当冲的不是盲目冲
也不是完全躲开
而怎么判断
怎么判断
他今天有可能黑K
或有可能红K
几率高不高
再跟各位讲
做交易都是看几率
几率高你就做多一点
我几率高
就是例如说
今天全新黑K的几率很高
所以我全新的
我今天就会做的比较多
今天做很多就帮我赚了400万
那假如今天黑K的几率
我觉得不高
我就做少一点
我甚至可以不做
不做就不会赔嘛
所以我可以不做
所以我们今天这样课
不是要给你名牌
是要教你一个当中逻辑
当中逻辑
你会知道什么时候该买进
什么时候该卖出
逻辑非常的重要
再跟各位讲逻辑很重要
好来看一下
这个小刚拥有丰富的当冲金
对我的名字后面有个歌
那我在当时做讲硬的时候
8月号到9月11号
我这个目的当冲的这个战绩已经赚了900多万
我们平均报酬率非常低
再给各位看平均报酬率非常低
只有0.47%
但是0.47%呢
我们不含
再跟我讲我们不含退佣
退佣什么意思
就是当你做的量够大
做的量够大
那么这个券商呢
他会
觉得量很大嘛
他会给你一个手续费的折让
手续费的折让
那有券商给你三折
有的给你两折
像小哥这种等级的
这种等级就是说
我一个月呢
做了几十亿的这种等级
各位看一下
像这边呢
当冲的部分
当冲部分在一个多月就做了在40亿一个月呢做几十亿的这种等级的话我们的手续费大概可以到一折多所以当你的量越大
你越能去跟人家谈手续费的折让
那手续费的折让有分两个
一个是日退
和一个是月退
那小哥呢是月退
月退什么意思
就说一个月到了
他会再把折让算一算
然后再退给我
那一个月到了
那像我现在的月退呢
我大概一个月的折让大概就是345
就300多万到400多万到500多万
我一个月的折让
折让的金额
所以呢我每个月呢
到了月中我还有一笔
一笔奖金
这笔奖金呢就是一个月的折让
所以呢你现在看到的这边的损益呢
还要再加上
像这边那还要再加上四五百万
就是我在当冲赚的钱
所以任何人要交你当冲
很简单
第一个你就问他说
你可以交税缴多少
只要缴的越多的
基本上
就是厉害的他
为什么因为
这一个月
我一个月要缴几百万交易税
我假如没赚钱的话
我不是做辛酸的吗
我早就做到破产了
我们现在一年缴的税是超过6000万
一年缴的税超过6000万
我一个月没赚个500万
我光缴税就要一个月缴500了
4500了
所以
有人要教人做当仇
明天要看看他到底有没有真的在做
因为只有厉害的人才能做大
不厉害的人做大
他一定赔成产一定很快就毕业
所以我们有丰富的当仇经验
那为什么有丰富的当冲经验呢
因为当冲还真的蛮有趣的
真的蛮有趣的
而且我们的胜率又高
重点在胜率高
你胜率低那不是有趣
那是很恐怖的
非常恐怖
所以当冲你一定要好好的研究
不能随便冲
你假如任何来做当冲
你没有任何策略
做当冲我就问问他说
你凭什么冲
我凭感冲
凭感冲一律出去
绝对挂
没有
只要凭感觉做交易
一定挂
当冲是所有交易里面最困难的
最困难的
所以各位呢
你要学当冲
好好的从筹码开始
从筹码开始
好
那真正的问题呢
这很多人都在评感觉冲
评感觉冲会有很大的问题
大部分人评感觉当冲
主力会让散户犯错
很简单吗
我每次呢
当冲
例如说我做空的话
我就发现国泰敦然
国泰敦然就散户
国泰敦然就在做多
就我在做空
他在做多
我是凭逻辑
凭数据
凭统计
我在做多
他是凭什么
他是凭感觉
我在放空
他是凭感觉在做多
所以当冲的两大核心重点
第一个
你要抓好红黑K的节奏
那什么叫红黑K的节奏
就是你要知道说
今天这档股票会红K
还是黑K
最重要的
今天这档股票会红K还是黑K
今天这档股票会不会红K
会不会黑K
它有很多因素在后面
那红K、黑K
场不场也很重要
因为有些股票你不能冲
为什么
因为它的红黑K很短
举下来讲
我给各位看一个当股票
中华电信你不能冲
它的红黑K很短
什么叫很短
你看它每天143到145
这个才1%多
才1%多
你每天要充它很难充的
所以我们要充的股票
那个K棒最好长一点
K棒长一点
那红黑K最好明显一点
要明显一点会比较好做
那当充它不一定要用现股充
它也可以用
那个股票起货充
那像今天全新呢
今天全新我做什么
今天全新我用个股充
我也用个股期来冲
就个股期货来冲
那今天全新我们在两天前就知道
它会黑黑了
至于为什么呢
欢迎你去上储置课
储置课有非常详细的说明
我们大概知道说今天会黑黑
所以我今天全新就冲的比较大一点
比较大就有比较好的获利
通常当冲再送各位一句话
赢要充输要缩当你当中赚钱你才能放大部位当你当中赔钱你要说起来你不能放大部位很多人做股票一个很大的问题是
他赢呢
赢怎么样
赢他不会冲
他输的时候
他非常冲
输的时候下大柱
抓狂起来拼命下
那个一次就会输很惨
所以我们都说
你真的要加码
一定要在赢钱的状况
输钱最好不要加码
除非你的策略很明确
所以当中两大核心中文
第一个抓好红黑K的节奏
第二个抓好买卖盘捷径的点位
抓好买卖盘捷径的点位
我们就一直在干嘛
我们一直在示范给各位看
各位你可以去上我的FB
或者是我的IG
我们都有买卖盘捷径的点位
我们都会贴
例如说像这个
买卖盘捷径的点位
我们在这边都会贴
我当冲的状况
这里都会贴
这不是
我们这里贴了很多买卖盘捷径的点位
像这边
一拉高买盘捷径
这边我们会扣
那刹下来
卖盘捷径我们会买回来
那这边呢有很多买卖盘
除了像这里
我盘中都没空
一拉高开始空
这边先空一笔
这边再空第二笔
再空第二笔
所以呢
当中的加减码
还有抓转折的能力
特别重要
尤其是当中呢
你对这档股票
红黑K的判定
非常重要
再跟各位讲
红黑K的判定
像这边就是抓转折
抓转折
那我们这个做当中就会贴一些
这个股票呢
在我们的脸书或IG
像这样的股票我们叫做隔日补铁股
那到底什么叫隔日补铁股呢
我们当中的课程都会详细的解说
那你知道什么状况呢
它就容易补铁
容易补铁呢
它就容易黑黑
所以呢
我们做交易都有理由在
再跟Rui讲一次
做交易你都要有理由
你假如没有理由
凭感觉做当冲
你就别冲了好不好
别冲了好好的去买0050什么事都不要做就买0050就好你凭感觉充卖者不要做了好不好你一定要好好的做
好好的学习筹码
好
那以上是我对当初的
这个一开始
这个献给各位
当初的一些知识
那我先自我介绍一下
我叫全政小哥
我是证交所
证交所有些课程的我去上
我也是CME
CME 这是美国
美国最大的期货交易所
指定讲师
这两边的讲师我都有去
三度全国交易赛事冠军
还有年交易岁数千万的现役操盘手
我七个月十万滚出一千万
这是以前的故事
后来这次三个月
我又从一千万滚了一亿多
三个月我们用我们的处置的战法
又滚到一亿多
那月成交让60亿
那这个我是从全镇翻身的
那著有全镇小哥短线终极这马灯
五本财经畅销书
I teach what I do
最重要的就是
我教的就是我用的
那这边呢
是我以前得到的奖
人生第一台双臂脚踏车
人生第一台马六
这是之前保的全镇抢
第一届台湾全王大赛的冠军
现在已经好像第14届了
然后这近期呢
这个群艺的比赛
这边呢我都有得奖
那这是我的粉专
目前有24万
那我的IG呢
目前大概快4万
里面都有一些影片可以看
那我的Train呢
目前是6万多
每天呢
大概都会更新一下
这个交易的资讯
那我是Pressplay第一名订阅作家
从2018年到现在
那我是Smart
2023年6月的封面人物
Smart杂志
那Smart课程好学
这个我有里面的
这个课程的内容
那我也是理财答案秀固定的嘉宾
理财答案秀
我大概每个礼拜会去上一次
那我是西班尼呢
这个西班尼理财宝
里面的固定的讲师
那我们也是专门的来做
那个软体的开发
企划
我也是YouTuber
目前有10万订阅
我还有一个银色的奖牌这些是我是我的书第一本是我书 不是这些第一本是我的畅销书
这些是我的书
这些是我的书籍
那我会赞助这个哨棒邀请山
蛮喜欢小朋友的
捐给国中的这个
也是跟棒球队有关的
小哥那边要再小一点
他挡到了
挡到太多天线
这边挡到
你说这脸
我再小一点
那我热爱帮球
所以我带国企来加油
那我在
这是在台大的
台大的上课
他给我一个
一个
一个纪念
这也是台大的社课
台下深刻
当年蛮多人的
然后呢
我有在高等法院演讲
里面演讲内容是
投资陷阱何其多
那我呢
喜欢日本
常常去日本
这是我在日本夹的娃娃
非常多
这是我在日本到过的地方
我比日本人还日本
日本人在他玩的地方
还没有我玩的多
那这边是我会参加各式各样的演讲
这个财经超能力的
然后我们也会办学院的聚餐
这边都学院聚餐
那我敢办学院的聚餐
这是我们的方法很有效
所以学院很开心的来聚餐
很开心的来聚餐
那这是这个学院的
带着学院还有带着我妈妈的
一起出游
然后这是上次上处置课的实体课
好了
所以这以上呢
简短自我做个介绍了
12月去北海道会看到小哥吗
12月去北海道
不会
好了
那首先我们来讲这第一章
当初判断K棒
K棒很重要
K棒呢
各位你要知道红K跟黑K
那什么叫红K呢
红K就收盘价比开盘价高
黑K就是收盘价比开盘价低
那我们这个
这边有一个实体
红黑K
实体红K呢
就是开玩家跟玩家之间的状态
那
这个黑K就是玩家比较近
这是实体的
那上面叫上影线
底下叫下影线
K棒主要这四个数字组成
那通常来讲
我们这个做当中的
它你可以赌红K也可以赌黑K
也可以赌红K
你可以赌红K
也可以赌黑K
那跟各位讲
红黑K会跟什么有关
各位你看一下这里
红黑K来看一档股票叫威刚
看威刚
红黑K跟什么有关
这里
跟什么有关
红黑K你看这边有很多红黑K
红黑K跟什么有关
跟主力买超有关
但主力买超呢
你是在盘后才知道
你在盘后才知道
那有没有什么东西呢
你可以在盘中就知道
再讲一次
有没有什么东西你可以在盘中就知道
那有一种东西叫做什么
叫做自营商
那自营商的买卖呢
你在盘中呢
是有可能会先知道的
为什么
因为自营商的买卖呢
跟全证有关
再讲一次
自营商的买卖跟全证有关
所以全证大买
自营商就容易大买
各位看一下这边
全证大买
自营商大买
他就容易红K
再给各位看一下
全镇大买自营商大买
他就容易红K
那反过来呢
全镇大卖自营商大卖
他就容易黑K
再讲一次
全镇这个
全镇这边卖超
这边还没有到大卖
自营商卖超他就黑K
那这个全镇卖超呢
搭配
你看这边
全赠卖超
自营商卖超
然后他就黑K
所以呢
全赠的买卖
会影响到自营商的买卖
那自营商的买卖呢
自营商呢
他有可能是在这前15大分点里面
那自营商的买卖呢
就会影响到
他的红黑K
所以呢
各位呢
你要做当冲的第一步
你可以先从全镇开始想先从全镇开始想当全镇大买的时候自营商就会大买他就容易红K
你就用这个方法去想
像威刚各位看一下
威刚呢全镇大买的都有一个分点
这分点叫国票
这是城市交易的
城市交易你会发现
他大买红K
大买红K
大卖黑K
大买黑K
他买就红K
买大概率红K
没有说一定红K
买就大概率红K
大买就容易红K
这个卖就容易黑K
我想是容易没有一定
没有一定黑K
但是百分比来讲
买了就容易红K
卖了就容易黑K
这个我们是用自营商的角度看
你也可以用隔日冲的角度去看
也可以
隔日冲大买容易红K
格冲卖了容易黑K
但格冲的股票呢
有的很强的股票呢
你不要去堵他黑K
再讲一次
格冲的股票有的很强的
不要堵他黑K
那个很危险
例如说像最近的汤河
具有科技
那个严上伟阻力买
那个要不要去随便堵他黑K
那所以呢
这个做当冲呢
就是你要先判断自己说
你今天要做红K策略
还是黑K策略
红K策略呢
你就是先买再卖
黑K策略呢
就是先卖再卖
红K策略就先买再卖
黑K策略先卖再卖
那有人问
假如没有权证怎么办
没有权证
那么要嘛你去找有权证的标的
没有权证你不一定要做啊
你懂我意思吗
没有权证不一定要做
这个当冲是这样
当冲你要去找波动大的标的
没有波动你不用做
没有权证你也可以不用做
那有权证呢
因为权证助涨助跌
假如今天权证大买
然后呢股票往上涨
他就怎么样
这张就继续买
所以会助涨助跌
假如今天股票跌了
权证大卖
这张卖潮
他就继续跌
助涨助跌
所以有权证的标的呢
会比较好做
我现在要教的都是帮各位提升你的当中胜率提升你的当中胜率提升你当中赢的几率赢的几率懂吗所以呢有很多当中是很难赢的
你可以选择不要做
来 举来讲
像我前一天有做一个当中叫新兴
那新兴这个是怎么样
这个跟
全正就没有关系
这个是纯粹是连续跌停
连续跌停的打开容易哄开
那星星这个没有到连续了
这只有第一根
那因为星星的全职太大了
而且他第一根的理由呢
其实没有说很严重
他第一根的跌停的是检掉搜索
然后他检掉搜索这个事件呢
这毕竟跟当下他的这个经营呢
没有太大的关系
所以呢
那第一根跌停开始
你看新鲜股价又回去了
所以从新跌停
那时候我是期待它再跌个几根
我要好好抢
结果它第一根完第二根就打开了
那打开我们都会去做第一个动作
就是先买后买
因为这种大型股票跌停打开
尤其是连续跌停的
它当天红K级特别高
所以你要赌这种红K策略
你可以去找连续跌停
但是你手脚要快
好
现在第一个
第二个呢
旺气
旺气呢
这个我记得是地板股
那有的地板股出现的时候
我们也会去赌他的红K策略
红K策略
地板股出现是这样子
地板股出现之后
他很容易会有红K来交代
很容易会有红K来交代
所以呢
我有很多这个红K策略会做
那红K策略有这些
红K策略主要是今天的买方主动积极
买方越主动越积极
它越容易红K
所以像第一个全证做多股
全证做多的它就容易红K
第二个主投买进的
因为主力跟投信有一直在买的
由于在调整的过程中
投信一直买主力也在买
主力跟投信同时买的
它都容易红K
那主头板沿上轨呢
这是更强势的股票
它也会容易红黑那标峰向上股呢这是筹码很好往上涨的它也会容易红K所以呢其实各位呢你去学去找容易红K的股票
举来讲
我们在这个写奖印那时候
那时候强势股里面
当天加指数大跌的
全震做多
这边是全震做多的标的
那全震做多标的呢
这是盘中呢
他就会全震进来买
开始统计
那全镇做多标记
你看当天大盘大跌的过程中
它的红K的几率非常高
大盘大跌
结果呢各位看一下
这边前八档里面有七档是红K
所以呢
全镇大户今天买的红K几率就比较高
那为什么
因为全镇大户买超
自己商就会大买
那通常自己全镇大户买超
他都买今天的强势股
他不会买弱的
所以跟各位讲
当冲第一个很重要
你要找红K的股票
你可以来到当冲标股
选手强势股
找全证做多
因为全证助涨助跌
全证助涨助跌
所以你要去找
全证做多的股票
刚刚很多同学在问说
全证跟及时全证要在哪里看
好
全证跟及时全证
各位
你在这个软件
这软件来我介绍一下
全阵在这边
各位
当冲标股神手
这边就好了
这边就好
这边全阵做多
各位
今天大盘是一个超级大的黑K
有没有看到
可以看一下
今天大盘长这样子
今天大盘是长这样子
今天大盘是一个超长的
这个上影线的黑K
那今天大盘是操上影线黑K呢
它就会导致怎么样
导致今天很多股票
也会开高走低
因为大家都涨着一样
那这全正大户呢
各位呢你就可以从这里看
从这软题
这边当中标股神手
这里看得到
这边呢就看得到
这个这边看到
来这边有个这个全正大户
来
我们盘中选股这边
强势股全镇做多
这间全镇做多
我的
我的这边没更新
等我一下
我这边档掉了
这画面档掉
我把它重开一下
我这边的desk in档机了
desk in档机
等一下
把它重开一下
太久没开
它就档
来我再重开一下
desk in
我直接开desk in
给各位看一下
这边
这里
这边有个当冲标股成手
全镇做多股
那这边呢
是全镇做多股
今天因为这个
那个大盘
常上引线的关系
所以今天这个全镇做多股票
有的后面杀尾盘
因为很多股票是杀尾盘
不止他
有很多股票杀尾盘
今天弱势股呢
就是全镇今天卖的
这些是今天全镇卖
假如大盘杀尾盘
那全镇做空的就很多
他是这个盘中就比较弱
那这个大盘黑K的话
弱势股全镇做空的黑K几率就更高
那大阪桥红K的话
强势股
强势股的这个红K几率呢
就会特别高
强势股的红K几率
你看一下
像这一天
这一天这个全震做多的
这一天大阪我记得是开很低
然后走高一点点
那这边的红K几率就会比较高
所以呢
全震做多股
它背后是有全正的买盘
然后今天会有自营商的买盘
你今天找这些股票
它都是自营商大买
那由于它今天强势股
所以今天通常全正做多的股票
你会看到它今天可能就是外资买或投信买
它很少那种今天就自营商买
结果外资卖投信也卖的这种状况很少
大部分都是自营商买
那大家可能就搭配一个外资买
或三大富安铜买
这就是全振作多所以各位你要找强的股票你可以找全振做多的你也可以找主头买进的主头买进是主力买投信也在买
主头买进的
这个会是前一天的资料
前一天资料
那主头买进的呢
各位有些主头买进
像投信有的常常都连五买
今天买隔天也会继买
在调整的时候
所以主头买进的
最近筹码比较好
这种你也可以找来做红K的策略
红K就先买后卖
先买后卖
还有主头卖沿上轨
这是更强势的股票
主头卖沿上轨
主力投进买超级
股价容易上涨
沿上轨攻击是一个短线强势的现象
或者是飙风向上股
这是更强
飙风向上股
盘中你可以找这些股票
但是你买之前
例如说不要像那种你买之前你要看一下
最好是这个
起涨的第一天
通常都是起涨第一天
之后你会看到
所以你不要买那种
已经涨了二三四
不要去买那种涨很多天了
这是做多的
做多的呢
我们这个比较喜欢找全证再买
全证再买呢
它会比较好
那全证做多的是当天资料
是当下资料
再跟各位讲
全证做多是当下的资料
他当下这些做多的
全证做多的
来看强势
全证做多
这是当下的资料
当下资料
全证做多
他越买越多了
他排行榜就会在越来越上面
当然知道这是红K策略
那再跟各位讲
做股票不是只有红K策略
我们也可以做黑K策略
然后呢
在做当冲交易里面
很多人都做错
做错什么
很多人他只喜欢做红K策略
那事实上
做交易呢
事实上是黑K策略
比较会赚钱
再给各位讲一次
黑K策略比较会赚钱
举例来说我常跟全人讲的一个案例
国据呢各位你可以去算一下
国据呢从100块涨到1000块从100块涨到1000块各位呢你今天一定要好好记得这个数字你可以自己去统计你做出来统计会跟我一样
从100块涨到1000块
这10年来
从100到1000
你每天早上一开盘买国具
尾盘卖掉
再讲一次
每天早上一开盘买国具
尾盘卖掉
你知道吗
你会赔了2300块
即便他从100涨到1000
你早上开盘买进
尾盘卖掉
赔2300块
赔的比他股价还多
更何况你每天要缴税
缴手续员那你一定赔
反过来说
我每天开盘先卖国具一涨
收盘买回来
这10年加起来
赚2300块
再讲一次
每天开盘卖一张
收盘买回来
这时你还赚2300块
但是你还是没赚
为什么
因为你每天要缴交易会主缺
你还是不会赚
好
那第三个
那我假如每天收盘买国去
隔天跳空
不管大涨大点
我隔天跳空卖掉
我可以赚3000多块
所以这故事告诉我们什么
这故事告诉我们
你要做当中
黑K策略比较值得做
所以呢我们长期
做很多黑K策略
所以你常看到
我的那个贴的那个当中点位
常常做黑K
像我今天全新闻是做黑K
黑K策略
那黑K策略就先卖再买而已
先卖再买
那各位看一下像我之前做望宏
这我一天
一天内做的
这边期货赚200多
我是开两个期货户头
我这边赚了500多万
然后这边是现股做
那这边这件是现股做
我现股当天可以做到3000多层
那期货呢
可以做到这个两个户头
赚了这个500多万
所以呢
我是靠数据交易
利用当冲神器
单日破千流年
破千我是做一档股票就破千
做一档股票破线
当我觉得那一天黑K纪律特别高的时候我会利用期限或大作这是以前的战机我也用今天的全新告诉你全新我今天也赚了400多
所以当我觉得它黑黑几率特别高
那一天我们就会大做
用期货做 用股票做
期货跟股票都可以做
当天就是我先卖战
命运码 这边空很多
后面都是补比较多
成交4亿
是当天的状况
所以呢
黑K股票的特性
怎么样
今日卖方主动积极
那怎么叫主动积极
第一个全正做空
第二个主投卖出
第三个弱势严下跪
第四个隔日冲
点点点
后面还有很多
那全正做空呢
你可以点弱势股
全正落空
再跟各位讲一下
这个在当冲标股神手
当冲标股神手在这里
当冲标股神手
落势股点下去有全镇做空
这里有全镇做空
你看今天全镇做空的
只有两档红黑
全部都黑黑
所以你去找全镇做空
你要做空要找全镇做空
那他今天呢
都全镇卖自营商卖
那叫今日落势股
那
这边打错了
这今日落势股
那这个
这一张呢
它会主动卖
然后呢
股价呢
就怎么样
就会下跌
股价就会下跌
这里
这一张会卖
肩股票就下跌
这个全程做空
那第二个
主头卖出
主头卖出的股票
主力卖投信卖
主力卖投信卖它会延续
延续
投信有时候卖它就会延续
投信跟外资不一样
投信常常延续
主力在卖投信也在卖
今天投信继续卖
所以继续卖它就黑K级率比较高
所以我们做当中都要跟筹码
你都要研究去研究筹码
你研究自己上的筹码
研究投信的筹码
那外资筹码你比较难研究
因为外资反反复复
有时候波段
有时候短线
你很不好抓
那投信比较好抓
资金商也好抓
资金商我们盘中就帮你抓
好
左头卖是不是这样
主力大要卖
股价容易走落
那落势股沿下轨
落势股沿下轨就是1,50,20,20
主力都会卖
那今天落势股
股价沿下轨
那隔日冲啊
隔日冲是这样
隔日冲每天呢
这个你盘中看起来会一堆
这个是收盘的时候看起来会一堆
收盘的时候看起来会一堆红
来看一下
这边呢
来看今天红
这是收盘你看到的样子
收盘你看到样子
来看一下
像今天的隔日冲
这是指说明天有隔日冲的股票
隔日冲股票你做起来就要特别小心
因为这些都是今天很强的股票
所以呢
你假如要去空隔日冲的股票
那个难度就增加了
很容易被尬空
再讲一次
隔日冲你看他都很强
很容易被尬空
所以呢
要空隔日冲的股票
你一定要好好的学筹码
太强的不能空
主力连续买进的不能空
再讲一次
开步林源上尾不能空
主力连续买进的不能空
你要空的股票
一定要有很多做空的理由
才能空
然后很接近涨金板
你也不要空
所以空格日冲的股票
事实上它的难度比较高
那空格日冲股票
你的手脚动作要很快
因为它有可能
买盘接近
稍微跌一点
卖盘接近
后面有机会又往上拉
因为格日冲
他在市场上
他们的做法非常的活泼
所以要抠隔日冲股票
它没有你想象来的容易
没有想象来的容易
这个是跟各位讲
你要做多的股票跟做空股票
做多股票就是找全镇做多的
做多股票你可以找全镇做空的
你要做空隔日冲的股票
那个难度比较高
你一定要小心一点
第四个我们要去抓那个买卖盘捷径点通常我们就买盘捷径空那卖盘捷径再买回来
就是买盘捷径让你卖的
卖盘捷径让你买回来的
这就是买卖盘捷径的那个
这个当时的点位
我们吉拉买盘捷径会空在这边
那吉沙会卖盘捷径会买在这边
所以我急拉买盘捷径我是去卖的
那很多人就想说
小哥我急拉买盘捷径了
可是他为什么又在拉
那我再跟各位讲
这个当你做交易的时间越短
像当初做交易时间就很短
就是你可能每一分每一秒都在做交易
这交易时间越短
当交易时间越短它越困难
所以我常讲当冲真的很难
我们有很多学员在处置赚了大钱
也有学员在当冲赚钱
但是当冲的难度真的是比处置的难度来的高
因为它的时间很短
那你今天买盘捷径了
你在空
主力 隔冲主力也在卖
但是可能另外一派外资又进来大买
因为通常这种股票有的都蛮强
他有可能又把它买上去
所以你放工可能就被嘎了
所以本来就跟各位讲
当冲真的是难度比较高
因为难度高
所以你要学当冲
你一定要好好的来上我们的课
所以被嘎怎么处理
第一个务必挂好出价单
例如说你102块空
你可以挂104块回补
104块出价
104块出价你顶多赔2块
再加上手续位交易税
再加上一个滑价
你大概赔个3块
一张就赔3钱的意思
所以你挂好出价单
可以避免你停损停不下去的危机
所以被夸的时候记得要挂好出价单
第二个速度盘的时候不要动作
什么时候出场没有动作
你看到极拉极杀你可以不要动
各位你要记得一句话
空债股价涨不动
什么时候值得空
拉上去震荡一直震荡
拉不上去那时候才值得空那极拉会想到均线是寻找小培促长的机会假设你放空被拉上去了
再回来到均线
这时候有可能是小培的点
那第四个呢
别回补再买盘接近
就是你被拉了
结果你心态崩了
你不再买盘
你发现那买盘好强
你去回补反而不再买盘接近
所以那就比较可惜
那当冲有太多太多的美感
但是我们这一次
这一次的体育课
没办法一次跟你讲非常多
这是在这边跟各位讲
当冲的第一个
你一定要好好研究筹码
所以结语
其实第一个
当冲难度高
你要多训练你的停损的能力
真的难度很高
第二个
做好资金规划跟停损公司
手码当中交易期望值会比较好
那学政权当中策略呢
你不必成为小哥不需要大资金
通过解读数据建立自己的交易系统
成为下一个获利一号颜的学员
当中是真的比较困难
那我们今天获利为王
我们的全政小哥当中新手全攻略
这堂课呢
里面有非常多的案例
非常多的案例
所以呢
今天看懂一个判断
接下来把完整流程接起来
那当中金统全攻略呢
会从盘前的准备
风险的规划
盘中判断
盘后的检讨
我们呢
会给各位比较完整的学习
那这个五个学习重点
第一个当中基础
还有下单的准备
你可以认识风险
成本跟模拟操作
第二个盘前多空选股
教育盘前你要怎么选
准备观察名单跟交易计划
第三个盘中进出场判断
我会告诉你说
盘中呢
你看到买卖盘怎么挂单
大概率呢
是主力呢
它有什么样的又多或又空
那这些呢
你可以从盘中挂单
可以呢去猜得出来
所以这个是看懂条件练习判断时期
第四个呢
我们有大量的实战案例
这边最重要
要有大量的实战案例会告诉你说这档股票为什么这么做未来再出现我还是会这么做就像全新我们两天前就预告了我今天就是会弄全新
我今天会弄全新
两天前就跟你讲
上数字课的人大家也都知道
我今天就会弄全新
那你就对照案例做
你的胜率就好
第五个盘后检讨还有交易心法
回顾记录
找书调整方案
以上内容都包含在完整课程
完整课程
这个当中心统学功力
我们花了非常大的心力
去录制这堂课
所以
够课后呢
你会开始学
反复的复习
课程永久观看
一字也步调复习
第二个呢
自主交流
我们开放学员讨论
交了讨论的空间
大家会聊得非常开心
跟其他同学互相学起
第三个
循序限制
先选一套方法再做模拟记录
所以我们课程做完之后
你来购买课程之后
课程学习
自主练习
通才交流
我们盘中不会带单
跟各位讲
这个社群
盘中绝对不会带单
你想说
小哥我加入之后
你盘中是不是带我当冲
绝对没有
盘中自己冲都冲不完了
我们不会教你带
不会在盘中教你怎么做
但是呢
我们在教学呢
会教你说你遇到什么状况
你可以去读红K或黑K
这些呢
你看完整个课程呢
你就会了解
为什么我在当时我会这么做
好
那当心有全功率呢
这个课程云价1288
完整课程永久观看
那这个
现在呢
不用
特价只要9666
这是最特价的时候
那另外呢
另外最重要在这边
这个全套软体三者的机会
所以购客学员呢
你可以专属加过全套软体三者
这是很
全套软体是没有处置横系的
没有处置横系
旧版的全套 不含处置神器三者
不含处置神器三者 全套
第三者
里面没有抽法可以
那是小哥的
小哥的这个
当冲
这个盘中当冲神器啊
还有这个当冲标股神手啊
还有全方位啊
全方位啊
这个当冲标股神手啊
还有全方位
这还是一堆小哥的软体啊
可转载有的
没的哦
这全部
加起来全到三折
这个软体原价是45,000
三折加购价是13,500
直接限整31,000
很多人都是来
都是来干嘛
都是来买课程
然后他要去买软体的
因为他觉得软体太好用了
那平常软体的费用呢又比较贵
他就趁着
趁着当充课程的时候
他就可以去
加购这个三折的软体
那这是不完处置省期的
好
所以呢
你一年的需求选择选择方案
它有完整课程是9666
或是9666加13500
那这边呢会变成23166
第二年的蓄定价呢是13500
那今天限定
那未来呢
它就只有涨价的份了
限时方案在这里
限时方案在这边
所以呢
全套的就在这边
各位有买的话
你就可以去购买全套软体
好
在这里
那最后呢
这是我的官方LINE
对方案上有很多任何不清楚
又不好意思关于发问的
都欢迎你连续官方
联系官方的LINE
这边呢会跟你讲
那今天呢就是我们的
这个课程的直播呢
就到这里
这个一定会涨价
那这个呢
第二年续定价这个一定会涨
13000我已经涨了
已经讲很久了
他后面就是会涨了
三折一年吗
之后恢复原价
没有之后是这样
第二年续定价是13000
只要你续定就还是这个价钱
有续定都是这个价钱
续约都是这个价钱
续约都不会变
都不会变
课程中有交集我当中去
太多了
我们里面叫当充戏巧常常都是我在用的常都是我在用的像隔日补蝶谷隔日补蝶谷也是里面有很多里面有交很多
做多的赌红K的
做空的赌K策略
都有
那未来呢
我们再会把
像我今天为什么做全新
未来这个
为什么做全新的
我们再把它
录一段影片送给各位
好不好
我把今天赚400万的策略
我就在这堂课再加码送给各位
赚400万
这是期货
我还没讲现股
现股那边也赚钱
我就把跟各位讲
我把这一套最高胜率的策略
我今天在民股大赚的策略
我再另外再录一个影片
送给今天购买的学员
就是今天赚400万的策略
今天特别好
特别在今天我再送给学员
我待会就来录
录给各位看说
为什么我做这策略
那未来你都还会遇到相同的情境
最近类似情境的股票蛮多的
未来你只要按照我这方法
去赌这个黑黑
这黑黑的几率
我们这个长期观察下来
大概有70几%
70几%到80%
那你只要盘中做
你盘中做一做
你就知道说今天好不好做
好做你就做多一点
好做就做多一点
那这个策略呢
我今天呢再加码
这是在我们的方案里面没有的
我今天特别加码给今天购买的学员
今天赚400万太开心了
所以特别加码送给各位
我待会就来录
来录完之后呢
请小编上个字幕
然后再送给各位
就只有今天了
未来就没有了
未来没有
好 有没有什么问题
这个当中专码这么多会教今天做来一打
会啊
今天你学完之后
你做的股票就大概跟我很类似了
那当中记得
你一定要把危险的给避开
当中最重要就是危险避开
什么叫危险呢
我写的很简单嘛
第一个
跳空一字线
隔天无论如何都不要做我说涨停跳空一字线的涨停隔天天你都不要去做不要去做多也不要去做空因为那个难度很高
难度很高
有单买软体吗
没有
没有单买软体
你一定要买课程
才可以有这个优惠价
我跟各位讲
有一堆人都是为了这个软体优惠价来的
因为他单买软体太贵了
要三四万
他不如买个全套软体
原本要三四万的
现在买全套软体
只要两万三还送你一堂当冲的课
他用这个方法转捏一下
因为我们是买课程送全套软体
买课程你可以用三折价购买全套软体
相当于就是你买到很便宜的软体
然后里面含课程的意思
是这个意思
所以这个三者我们只给
只给你有购买影音客的人
好
那么里面很多软体
未来都会有网页版
所以各位呢
以后呢
你用手机看的
那个未来都会更
都会蛮方便
那么现在有很多
像这个除旋席
还有全方位
还有大宗标舞神手
这个都是APP
这个都有送
全化软件里面
这个都有
买电脑都送手机版
没有出自成器
没有
因为这个是
这处置成器太贵了
好不好
处置成器太贵了
处置成器就是
那个
那边太贵
因为处置成器
处置成器里面的
里面的东西太复杂了
到现在为止
那个软体工程师
每天都在猜证交所改的什么规则
跟各位讲
处置里面的规则
证交所偷偷改都不告诉你的
我们每天都要去从答案
去回推它的问题
要从答案去回推它的条件
所以那个是有点困难的
没有还处置生气
全道软体有哪些
来来来
来来来 这边
全道软体这边有
从分点
这个地板股
融券回补力道监控表这边都有还有这个个股事件获利网可转债个股事件获利网就是初线起在用的
初线起在用的
还有
一次开太多
他在读
还有可转债也有
个股事件获利网
地板股
我觉得抢版的很好用
抢版的很好用
天良进入地板股
明天不是叫场天良
因为这个股本比较小
我们都喜欢抢股本大的
这边最重要就是
我每天盘中都会看全方位监控
全方位监控这个有手机板
全方位监控里面有大户收密
有分点探索
有券商排行
这边都有
反正这里面有很多东西
东西非常的多
挑选古异小帮手
这个专门在算节算价
这软体含在内
重点就是当冲神器
当冲神器
当冲神器这一套就要9000多了
当冲神器加全方位
这两个合起来都16000
所以你可以用13000又买到
13000多买到这些软体
真的是很便宜
这是很便宜
这是难得的机会
我们现在没有常开放
那个购买课程有三套的机会
现在没有
现在都很少开放这个机会
好
新手如果听不懂
这个上课就新手
不用担心
听不懂的你也可以在康上问
也可以在社群里面问
好
今天影片会重播吗
会
因为重播一天
一天
就一天
买的人今天影片
可以看
购买的人
你今天影片你就会放上去
然后再加送一段
我今天赚400万的秘密
赚400万的秘密
我再跟各位讲
我今天全英文什么
我可以赚400万
那个软体这样子
很多人都说
它是Mac系统
所以我们现在有很多
像挑选全镇小帮
刚没有讲到
挑选全镇小帮手
这个也是软体其中之一
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:00:00 起〕